mon papa nous gardois
[Musique]
m
on est aujourd'hui à san francisco on
suit un petit test alors hier sur ce
truc là
si vous avez vu ça c'est le nouveau
samsung galaxy samsung galaxy s 20 ultra
lennon devienne un petit peu à rallonge
sur les smartphones hier a eu lieu le
même pack de la grande conférence pour
présenter ses nouveaux smartphones et
aussi le z flip départ a effectivement
de ses galaxy s 20 elle sera plus un
ultra ps voit tout court et aujourd'hui
on va se parler du z flip était de
présenter le nouveau galaxy et de fip
alors moi je trouve ça vachement
intéressant parce que les smartphones
pliable en règle générale ce qu'ils
faisaient c'est qu'il venait à y rentrer
en tout cas ce qu'on a vu avec le fol
l'année dernière et là le z flip
l'idée c'est qu'il vient réfléchir pour
alain formant un peu plus compact donc
aujourd'hui on va se parler du z flip
moi j'aime bien parce que je trouve ça
cool c'est l'idée de ce format toi qui
l'as eu venir un peu plus petit alors ce
qui est assez dingue c'est qu'on n'a pas
le processeur le plus puissant en
postant d'avoir un sabre a connu 165 là
dessus non on a 1 855 plus ce qui est à
peu près 30% moins performant que le
juge page et isole 865
néanmoins c'est pas la promesse qui nous
fait la promesse qui est faite là-dessus
c'est pas d'avoir le le socle plus
performant le truc le plus dingue mais
par contre d'artus très compact face
dans la poche et qui est à ses côtés
des succès
taïga
dgo
le matching bad
c'est parce que les clients regardent un
beau gosse sur sur ce chemin de fer par
garde il me propose donc du coup
plusieurs photos plusieurs vidéos que tu
vas pouvoir poster sur les réseaux
sociaux
heureusement le beau gosse et attend là
il me propose une photo de toi en mode
portrait alors que j'étais pris en vidéo
tu sais ça marche super bien
mauricio prix vois-tu ton très surpris
voire très attendu call pas mal de toi
non du tout pas mal du tout à l'eau
salubre et la maman et près de thouars
franchement le single take c'est un truc
de ouf
selon cet accord c'est un truc de fou je
prends une petite vidéo tranquillou 10
secondes et tout est fait d mode
portrait un salut des noir et blanc et
un nom on voudrait les galaxies bessèges
et ultra avec moi et comme le mode
single sing qui est assez impressionnant
vrais potes ouais je m'attendais en fait
que ce soit un truc du genre trois
secondes ipsum en fait je choisis la
durée et en crée autant de contenu que
tu veux tu peux supprimés après pas mal
franchement j'aime beaucoup pour les
pour les fans de réseaux sociaux sec
comme ça
ça
tu n'as plus tard
c'est un truc est bien avec ce
smartphone c'est qu'en fait la charnière
on voudrait pas l'ouvrir une position
ferme et une position verte comme son
annexe sur le galaxy folk classique
vous avez plusieurs positions qu'on les
règle est vraiment comme vous voulez au
niveau de votre degré d'ouverture donc
ça chauffe ça coule en plus résistants à
l'avant vous avez une surface en verre
et ça c'est drôle parce qu'on n'a pas ce
côté un peu trop plastique sont touchées
on est un corps nu gorilla glass 6 il ya
un côté un peu plus près alors on n'a
pas la sensation d'un smartphone d'un
petit peu standards comme ce qu'on
pourrait avoir avec un galaxy s 20 c'est
pas exactement la même chose sous le
doigt néanmoins le touch est quand même
relativement l'écran que vous avez
intérieur ça l'écran de 6,7 pouces je
trouve relativement grand quand même pas
mal pour avoir vraiment dû du confort de
visionnage on a vraiment l'expérience
d'un grand smartphone c'est celle du
full hd c'est un format fans de noël
viennent on est quand même relativement
allongé cdu 2636 par 1080 pixels est
vraiment un peu bâtard mais qui dans
l'absolu a l'air plutôt fonctionné et à
l'extérieur vous avez un tout petit
écran de notification de 1,06 pouces
c'est aussi un écran super amoled avec
du corning gorilla glass 6 avec une
résolution de 300 part sans cesse pixels
autant dire que les gens attendaient un
grand show c'est par l'écran où on va
venir regarder du contenu on peut voir
un petit peu aucune espèce de certains à
côté un petit peu visionnage lorsque
vous voulez même regarder une photo où
vous vous prenez quelqu'un vous tous
vous dire tiens regarde un petit peu 4
en jetons alors c'est tout petit c'est
pas très simple mais surtout ça vous
sert quand le cac va vous appeler ça
vous marque qui vous appelle vous pouvez
venir décrocher vous voyez qui vous
envoyer un message fort c'est vraiment
l'idée d'un petit écran de notification
bien plus petit que ce qu'on a vu sur le
foll pas si c'est la meilleure solution
est ce que fait motorola avec son razer
c'est mieux peut-être avoir nola
attendant comme ça je vole pour mon chat
[Musique]
là où ça un assaut lancé dans une
galerie et on va se faire un atelier
graffiti
quand vraiment hyper kasma hyper urban
culture 2 san francisco c'est hyper cool
là on a un atelier effectivement où on
vient faire des grappes nous mais nous
évaluerons style extérieur dans son jeu
son hyper en difficulté lors je suis à
fond
paper en difficulté mais c'était bon
vas-y fais quoi là complètement
[Musique]
m
le sucre à 26,25 graffiti vient
d'acquérir et s'habituer je sais pas si
vous n'allez même modèle de pensée du
chat en fait ça me fait penser aux vieux
rasoir de l'époque
si vous connaissiez espèce de rasoir
électrique dans les années 80-90 que
vous passiez comme ça et ce qui est
extrêmement drôle c'est que vous avez
avec vos poils qui coince ça fait un peu
rasoir ça on sait pas l'idée de l'objet
et en fait ça c'est le deuxième
détournement qu'on dépense à ce
smartphone serait comme les smartphones
sont sortis il ya vous posez votre
smartphone guerre des consoles dans les
galaxies
posez votre smartphone sans l'ajout et
tout au début où les soirs quand on
sorti par rapport au vieux téléphone
j'interviens devant la bouche on dit
mince est-ce que l'on va passer alors
clairement oui c'est un peu des des
trucs de l'époque vous savez qu'on
téléphone avec micro devant la bouche et
on vous êtes vous retrouvé que celui-là
faire vous ouvrez votre smartphone vous
l'avez comme ça et tac vous le mettez
devant vous avez le micro devant la
bouche alors je ne sais pas si ça marche
bien comme ça je pense pas que ça soit
vraiment grand chose mais santiago tout
cas moi ça fait mal
ah ah
à
ce qui fait vraiment grand dole ne
protège pas brandon nos collègues
c'est malheureusement
[Musique]
qui fait loi
il fait beau
tous ont dit
[Musique]
le fait est là
non
mais
la bleue
vous faites
musée se diviser
faire
je voulais pas dire mais quand c'était
hawaï petite anecdote chute hawaï on est
allé se baigner avec wwa est donc en
fait les monsieur bois
la légende
tu as mais dans ce que ça peut donner
aussi au niveau de la batterie parce qu
on a quand même l'écran 6,7 plus qu
assez énorme
on a une batterie de trois mille trois
cent millions paire eur bon ça peut être
pas mal voir la question d'autonomie ce
label évidemment on en reparlera lors du
day 2 vous invite maintenant à vous
abonner s'est pas déjà le cas comme ça
serait tout vous avez de la recharge
rapide 15 watts et de la recharge sans
fil 9 fois que si on veut en plus vous
avez de la recharge à verser pour venir
charger vos galaxie buzz côté photo vous
avez deux capteur de 12 mégapixels un
capteur principal 78° avec une ouverture
de f 1.8 et un deuxième c'est un ultra
grand angle 123 degrés bref deux points
de bris à l'avant des caméras 10
mégapixels f 2.4 bon à voir tout ça bien
évidemment par ait plus lors du test
si on n'a pas les derniers à techno en a
pas de wifi 6 par contre on a du
bluetooth 5.0 vous pouvez à pareille
époque avec ses buzz sans problème ça
marchera très bien
[Musique]
et de ce soir
les aztèques everywhere les dents
longues
regardez ça bosse c'est incroyable vous
êtes sûr que cela tu bosses je fais
toujours mon service
toi tu te tutoie tu bosses toit vitré
galaxie bottes les nouveaux choix
on va lui là ils bossent chez moi ouais
ouais tu me laisses à côté bost toi mon
quand tu bosses pas toi car tu as tu
t'amuses toi tu es un conteneur pour ces
cas là mais d'apprendre qu'elle mwc qui
était annulé pas de mw cette année pas
de plaintes contre des shu pitot de sa y
aura pas mais on voit comme les produits
je sais pas on les aurait alors dit
content qu'il voyait de truc à moi de
faire y compris ceux qui sont prévus
donc en vacances
donc voilà donc la départ on a quoi 11
heures de vol à peu près san francisco
paris et en ce qui me concerne il ya une
heure de stop à paris et ensuite c'est
paris londres et on parlera de plein de
choses mais ça sera demain
[Musique]
bon voilà pour la fin de ce périple a
maintenant c'est l'heure de rentrer je
vous invite à me dire ce que vous pensez
de ce smartphone de samsung comment vous
trouvez le galaxy z flip est ce qu'il
vous intéresse est ce que vous le
trouvez bien qu est ce que vous pensez
de tout format par rapport aux folles
est ce que c'est un format qui vous
paraît intéressant est ce qui vous
paraît pertinent mark et moi tout ça on
va en commentaire non on retrouve demain
et là c'est l'heure de partir de rentrer
parce que voyez il ya 11 heures et
quelques de boxe vallorbe pas mal sans
les conditions de retour pour vous dire
franchement on n'est pas mal qu'on
voyait dans un business qu'on a de la
chance car c'est ça le fait regardez ça
là comme ça il ya de quoi ranger toutes
ses petites affaires
j'ai beaucoup de place pour étendre mes
jambes je suis là l'écran ont justement
dans les territoires bosser parce qu'il
ya un montage à faire donc pas tendre
dans merde en kabylie se fera ici
heureusement ça s'allonge
on peut donc faire un gros dodo voilà
pour ceux des mises en place dans les
rues demain non retirés par les tec
[Musique]
chaud
ces bons qui des abonnés
[Musique]
las